From stuffed unicorn in-jokes to
secret Witcher game references,
Season 2 is loaded with hidden details you
might have missed the first time around.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan, and
in this video I'm revealing all the very
best easter eggs and call-backs in
the second season of The Witcher.
Spoilers ahead, of course, so take care.
When Yennefer meets Ciri in the sixth episode
after the young princess stumbles
in on her and Geralt kissing,
the way he introduces them is a
little easter egg for book readers.
This is my…
uh, dear friend.
This is a nod to the letter Geralt
wrote to Yen in the books after they'd
been separated for a long time and how he
awkwardly addressed her as "Dear Friend".
Dear friend?
Later on, Ciri asks Yennefer about unicorns and
whether they really exist, to which Yen replies:
I used to own a stuffed one.
Until it broke.
Under mysterious circumstances.
Notice how, in the show, Yen looks at Geralt
after she replies, he gives her a half-smile,
then she smiles knowingly to herself.
Ciri's follow-up that she'd like to meet
a unicorn herself one day is a reference to how
unicorns really do exist in The Witcher universe,
and a hint at how in the books she meets and
befriends one called "Little Horse" which she
also uses to jump between worlds.
In the middle of the Great Hall at
Kaer Morhen is a medallion tree;
and after Eskel dies, Vesemir adds
his medallion to the many others there which
serve as a memorial to the fallen witchers.
In this close-up shot, we can various styles
of medallion, but this particular design
here is an easter egg to The Witcher game.
Another interesting detail on the reverse
of Eskel's medallion, which we
can also see on Geralt's costume,
is an intricate spiral of symbols.
These appear to be inspired by the
real-life Phaistos disc whose meaning has
been hotly debated by scholars for decades,
though one interpretation is that the symbols
are a Minoan prayer to the mother goddess.
The Netflix show isn't afraid to get a
little meta several times this season;
for instance, when Jaskier meets someone
who comments on one of the bard's songs.
It's a bit complicated.
Took me to the fourth verse to
understand there were different timelines.
That's a nod to the somewhat confusing
nature of the show's first season and its three
separate timelines which eventually converged.
That magic kiss?
That was a bit cheap.
There, he's referencing Geralt and Yennifer's
mid-battle kiss in the dragon cave.
That was Geralt using Yen's magic to strengthen
his Aard blast, but it was also mocked by some
fans as being cheesy and a little cringey.
I spotted the dragon reveal a mile away.
Oh, you're clever.
That's the twist that
Borch who hired Geralt for the dragon hunt
was actually a golden dragon himself.
Although there's no Geralt bath tub scene this
season to continue the meme from the game,
we still get the running joke
about how badly he smells.
You can bathe in the next room.
You reek of old horse.
Yarpen uses a unique-looking weapon with a
metal hand during his attacks this season.
And the show's armoury department created
an equally intriguing backstory for it
which features Yarpen cutting the hand off
a Nilfgaardian sentry after a disagreement
then getting it cast in bronze.
And notice that, in a similar vein,
two of the other dwarves in his crew have
weapons with a metal foot on the end!
When the Deathless Mother tucks
Ciri away in a fantasy world,
we get a replay of events in Cintra from the
first season with some interesting twists.
So, when Martin asks Ciri to dance, this
time around she accepts willingly…
Would you honor me with a dance?
-She would love--
-I'd love to, Martin.
…in contrast to how originally Ciri
really didn't want to but Calenthe made her.
Would you honor me with a dance?
Uh…
Martin--
She'd love to.
The idea here is that she's just happy to be with
her dead relatives again rather than feeling like
it's an obligation like she did the first time.
This fake reality does break apart a little, of
course, as Geralt tries to reach through to Ciri;
and it's only on for a moment, but at one
point Mousesack's face suddenly flips to an
image of the Doppler assassin who killed him
in the first season and took on his form until
revealing his true nature to Ciri and Dara.
The Netflix show's first season already introduced
some magical signs that are popular in
The Witcher games, and we also get to
see some more cool ones in Season 2.
So, when Geralt is battling the Bruxa's
piercing screams in the first episode, he
casts a Quen sign which forms a defensive
shield against the sonic waves.
He also appears to cast it later to
create a protective barrier when the Myriapod
attacks him in the woods although this might
be the alternate Heliotrop sign which only
protects against a single physical attack.
And the way Geralt lights up his
blade could be either the Igni sign,
or a temporary fire rune which he can
apply to his sword in The Witcher 2 game.
And in the final battle with the Deathless Mother
and the basilisks, Geralt casts an Yrden sign
Yrden, now!
which can block and slow down monsters
from entering an area protected by the sign.
He uses this so he can attempt to negotiate
with Voleth Meir and get through to Ciri without
having to fight the basilisks at the same time.
Geralt's mention to Ciri of a
nightmare about an overly friendly
rock troll appears to be an easter egg to the
somewhat chatty trolls in The Witcher 3 game.
Can we talk?
Sigi you like.
Talk me with.
There's a big clue you
might have missed to Season 2's twist ending
that Ciri's father Duny is still alive;
but just before we get to that, if you'd
like to try out another immersive gaming
world like The Witcher, who've
kindly sponsored this video.
It's a great low-stress multiplayer combat game
where you can fight with friends or team up with
them in a global arena of other players.
There's a fantastic choice of combat robots
you can trick out from bad boy Guardian,
to speedy Killshot, and ninja-like Shadow.
And if you're a fan of Witcher's weird and
wonderful monsters, you'll like the Arachnos,
a spider tank you can load up with weapons and
which has a nifty little spider turret you can
drop to do some damage while you take cover
or use for a double-attack on an opponent.
Mech Arena also hosts some amazing
contests like the Mechs Are Here
event where the winners got to pilot a real-life
mech and which also raised $100,000 for charity!
Twelve customisable pilots are an exciting
new feature arriving in the game this month,
plus there's a packed schedule of holiday events,
Battle Pass season 2 and new Deathmatch maps.
Mech Arena is completely free to play on
Android and iOS right now, so hit my personal
link in the description below to grab a pack of
bonuses including an exclusive Mech Heraldic,
3 Gold Crates plus 50,000 Credits.
If you watch events in Ciri's dream world very
closely, when she eventually decides to leave,
her grandmother, Mousesack and mother all fade
away to dust because in reality they're dead.
However, notice how her father standing
next to Pavetta doesn't fade away,
because he's actually still alive.
When Jaskier the bard pops up
performing his latest song in episode 4,
he's wearing a broad-brimmed hat with one
side pinned up, complete with feathers.
If the look of that hat rings a bell, that's
because according to the costume designer
it's inspired by the cavalier hat worn by
Puss in Boots from the Shrek franchise.
Pray for mercy from...
Puss...
in Boots!
Jaskier's song "Toss A Coin To Your Witcher"
was an instant hit when the series first debuted;
but his much angrier follow-up, "Burn, Butcher,
Burn", signals how he feels about Geralt
after being rejected by him in Season 1.
And, interestingly, to reflect that, this
time rather than encouraging his audience
to tip the Witcher, he's collecting
the coin for himself instead.
Like the first season, the second season's
episode logos are easter eggs to significant
characters and moments in the show.
The winged vampire symbol for the
first episode references the bruxa
Vereena who lives with Nivellen.
The vines growing out of the wolf's
head in the second episode's logo
foreshadow Eskel's fate and how the leshy
monster will end up growing inside him.
The swallow in episode 3 represents Ciri, whose
name derives from the Elder word for swallow.
The sixth episode hand with fingers that turn
into flames is a reference to the mage Rience
who can conjure fire from his bare finger.
Interestingly, the way he gets his facial
burns in the show, when Yennefer blows alcohol in
his face while he's holding up a fiery finger, is
a nod to how she burned his face in the books by
sending a fire spell through a closing portal.
And Rience's partner-in-crime Lydia gets her
facial disfigurement after attempting to blood
trace the stolen vial of Ciri's Elder Blood, which
is a hat-tip to how she was similarly injured in
the books after experimenting on a mysterious,
cursed object found in a necropolis.
The final episode's logo of spheres colliding and
smashing into shards which reform into a tree are
not only a reference to the Conjunction of the
Spheres, but also a hint to the reveal of a hidden
monolith inside the Witcher Medallion Tree and
how Ciri will split the tree in two then shatter
the stone to pieces later on in the episode.
And there's a clue early in the season of Ciri's
connection to Season 2's monsters when Geralt
finds that branches from the leshy in Kaer Morhen
have entered Ciri's room and pulled the shawl of
her dead grandmother Calanthe into the walls.
There was a clue to the Deathless Mother bringing
basilisks into this world when Fringilla talked
about the scary stories she heard as a child:
Stories about the witch in the woods,
her home perched on basilisk legs.
The hut Voleth Meir was trapped in did,
in fact, have basilisk legs and is inspired
by Slavic legends of Baba Yaga, a wild,
mythical witch-like spirit who lives in the forest
and is said to live in a cabin on chicken legs.
There's a lovely tribute to Jurassic Park and its
iconic shot of a cup of rippling water caused by
the approach of a T-rex when Jaskier freaks out in
the finale at a bowl of moving water as it means
another monster is on its way!
Oh, seriously?
And this shot of a basilisk foot as
Jaskier hides under the table...
Right the wrongs?
Well, Yennefer, I don't
see how things could get any wronger!
reminds me of the kitchen scene where
the kids hide from the raptors in
Spielberg's first dinosaur movie.
If you look closely at Ciri's room at Kaer
Morhen and Yennifer's room in her dream
where she has a baby with Geralt, you'll
notice that both places are very similar,
including the window, door, walls,
and even position of the bed.
The reason for that is that show's creative
team made a deliberate decision to use the same
set for both Ciri and Yen in order to foreshadow
the close link between the two women.
To reflect the fact that Yennefer lost her power,
the show's make-up designer decided to tone down
Yen's make-up this season in order to give her
character a less magical, more neutral look.
And it's just a subtle moment,
but when Yen's magic does return
after she offers herself as a vessel for Voleth
Meir, her purple eyes come back as well.
I thought it was curious how Ciri's family
were dusted Avengers: Infinity War-style,
especially given that Witcher's showrunner
Lauren Schmidt Hissrich has said The Wild
Hunt are the show's Thanos, in other words
the overarching big bad of the series.
And Ciri herself a kind of Infinity
Stone-filled Gauntlet that everyone is now
chasing for her immense powers.
Netflix's Witcher is often compared
to Game of Thrones, and the show
itself sometimes pokes fun at that.
So, in the opening episode, when a
Nilfgaardian warrior begs for mercy
in the aftermath of the Battle of Sodden Hill...
... Vilgefortz's reply and his decision to kill
the soldier is a spin on Syrio Forel's
Game of Thrones catchphrase that The
Witcher takes and turns on its head.
What do we say to the God of Death?
Not today.
And coincidentally or not, the actor who
played fan favourite Tormund Giantsbane in Game
of Thrones plays Nivellen in that same episode.
When Tissaia records the names of the mages
who died at the battle of Sodden Hill,
as well as real Witcher characters from
the franchise, there are some made-up ones
such as this one here which is a shout-out to
Witcher showrunner Lauren Schmidt Hissrich.
A lot of hidden details much earlier in the
season foreshadowed Ciri's big finale and
to discover all the ones you missed, tap here
to watch my Season 2 Ending Explained video,
plus what to expect in Season 3 including the
mysterious character Rience and Lydia are working
for and how Ciri's father is still alive.
So, what other easter eggs, call-backs or
awesome details did you spot this season?
And what was your favourite moment?
Comment below and if you enjoyed this,
leave a thumbs-up, I really appreciate it.
And you can tap left for my full
breakdown of the Season 2 big finale.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!